So those would be sharp
minutes.
So where are we going to do,
we're going to pair you with an artist,
artists that you've never met
and never seen him before,
but in artists that typically people
wouldn't associated with your freedom and
y'all are going to make
something together.
How are you feeling right now on
your emotional climate for it?
Anxious. Excited. Oh Man.
Where are you to do something really cool?
Great.
Hello? Hello. How's it going? Sorry,
I'm Jessica. Nice to meet
you. Nice to meet you. Okay.
Oh,
is it a violin?
I was completely surprised
when d sharp walks in.
I definitely automatically assumed that
it was going to be me with a dancer.
Yeah. And I do a lot of
like electronic music. Yeah.
It's just like pop in things that you
wouldn't normally expect to see with a
classical instrument. Okay,
cool. I actually had no idea.
I kind of had a feeling that it
wasn't going to be a musician,
but a pleasant surprise.
Okay. So all right. Well
yeah, no. So
we need to make something.
What made you like one of the,
what's it like kind of
one of those things?
No, it's like I say, well studied dance
in a college setting and I was like,
I want to do something like really like
Raunchy and out of the box and like I
don't want anyone to know about it.
And then I went to class and my teacher,
she was like doing all this beautiful
stuff in the air and I was like,
she looks like a ballerina. As soon as
my first day was over I was like, why is,
why are no dancers doing pole?
Because it's looked down
upon as like a sexual erotic.
I mean that's why I took class.
I was the appeal for me.
Then when I showed up and saw
how beautiful it was, I was like,
this is exactly what I do is just,
yeah,
different form.
So interesting because I feel like
I kind of had a similar path like,
because you know,
starting with classical music,
I was going to always at rebel kids who
like I wasn't wanting to learn like the
songs off the radio.
Yeah. We're the Weirdos, pretty
much doing stuff. We're like,
why can't you do this?
Right.
If I think like laying down and
playing would be cool. Like,
and then like maybe if
you're walking through, um,
okay,
this is hard move if towards the beginning
of his life,
even a struggle between maybe it doesn't
really work out really beautifully at
first. Yeah. And then we kind
of have, we both have a similar,
we'll go down with similar message
photo.
Okay.
So this is just what it sounds like
great.
Today.
Like getting to play with d sharp is like
I love classical elements and the way
he brings it into a more modern feel.
This is like my jam.
Like I love hearing those ideas
taken into like this new way.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay. Okay.
I think it's really fascinating
how we have so much in common,
but even though we come from
completely different worlds,
our battle has still been
somewhat similar. Like
getting to where we are today.
I have not met anybody that's so like
me and so different than me at the same
time. So I feel like we
get along perfectly because
we're very strong and what we
liked, but we also are very
open to each other's ideas.
So it was cool to collaborate.
Overall, I think it's going to be
good, but I don't know. We'll see.
I'm definitely nervous,
but, um, I'm excited and I'm
happy for this opportunity,
so I'm excited to do it.
Yeah.
Rolling.
Oh,
thank you guys for
watching between worlds.
This is personally my favorite series a.
We can only make these
because you guys watch.
So do me a favor and watch some more.
Go ahead and click this
button to subscribe.
Go ahead and click that button to
watch more videos. I appreciate you.
I love you all and I'll see you
at the end of another video.